for us it's his dancing feat and his
cheeky personality that we'll always be
missing from our lives
this is clive trici with his sister
elaine at a family party
clive loved dancing holidays gardening
and art he drew this picture of his
favorite place in somerset
clive had a learning disability and
complex epilepsy and died in an
assessment unit in nottinghamshire at
the age of 47 yet another person who
spent years trapped in institutional
care
it matters what happened to clive it
matters it's still happening
to others
what happened to clive has been examined
by an inquest and multiple agencies but
only now in a review commissioned by nhs
midlands prompted by reporting by sky
news have serious questions being raised
about clive's life and his death after a
cardiac arrest
the review made more than 50
recommendations and concluded that
clive's death was potentially avoidable
it says clive's institutionalization
resulted in an unnecessarily prolonged
detention in hospital of nearly 10 years
and that he remained incarcerated in
settings that were poorly equipped to
meet his needs
and the report says that the post-mortem
and pathologists report failed to
consider sudden death in epilepsy as the
cause of clive's death
there is no justification there's
nothing on this planet could ever
justify anybody's incarceration
away from their family away from their
futures and away from their aspirations
hopes and dreams
the report says there are unanswered
questions about how clive was treated by
staff on the night he died and clive's
family want the contents of a memory
stick they found by chance in a box of
files reinvestigated
but all people around clive had to be
very cautious not to be stressing
which is why clive's family say they
want an explanation of this footage
found on the memory stick it shows staff
in the hospital corridors in the hours
before clive died the daughter clive's
bedroom is open and he is inside shared
with sky news it was never played at the
original inquest
from different angles staff are seen
leaving then return flashing torches
right outside clive's room another
flashes their torch multiple times even
though the lights are on in the corridor
and in clive's room
then a third person arrives
clive's family want to know if this
incident contributed to the seizure he
had several hours later they didn't have
epilepsy training skills knowledge
history background to understand the
implications of that torch the distress
he would have kept and tried to work
around all night
it took less historically for clive to
have a seizure triggered
took less
excitement
calendar dates appointments
this is the last image of clive going to
make a call to his sister in which she
says he sounded distressed he wasn't
wearing his seizure protection helmet
his family want to know if there had
been some kind of altercation with staff
who say he'd had a calm night and gone
to bed after having a hot chocolate
for months clive had been raising
concerns about his health and the way he
said he was being treated he wrote notes
saying he hadn't been given his glasses
his hearing aid and his seizure helmet
this photo shows clive's cpap machine to
help with sleep apnea was missing from
his room as it was broken the review
says he'd been without it for seven
weeks before his death
clive left this voice message on his
father's phone a month before he died
thank you dad
we all did
nobody listened
clive was one of 40 people who died
trapped in autism and learning
disability units between 2015 and 2018.
the government said those deaths were
not untoward but in clive's case this
review suggests otherwise
and sky news has learned since 2018
there have been a further 35 deaths in
these units 10 of which were people
under the age of
35. people are being placed in
situations that do not keep them safe
beverly dawkins wrote the review into
clive's death and says there is new
evidence in her report which can be used
to support the family's call for a
second inquest
it felt
like
given that we knew the ending that the
very sad ending it felt like sort of
watching a slow-motion train crash also
knowing that what happened in his life
may still be happening to other people
if the commitment to to move him to the
community had been carried through at
that point
he may still have been alive today
nottinghamshire police say the cctv
footage does not meet a criminal or
safeguarding threshold staffordshire
county council says it will review
safeguarding inquiries the nhs says all
deaths are investigated and they're
working to reduce the number of people
in units like clives
the hospital where he died has since
been taken over its new owners signet
healthcare say they have addressed any
areas for improvement and will continue
to share lessons learned lisa holland
sky news